floridians are keeping an eye on
tropical storm fred and bracing for rain
this comes as the state also grappling
with rising coveted cases and a debate
over some pandemic protocols joining me
now to discuss it francis suarez mayor
of miami mr mayor thank you for taking
time i want to get to that tropical
depression fred but first let's talk
about the situation with covet cases
you're somewhere just shy new positivity
rate uh just shy of 19
how are things going there who is most
impacted
well many people are being impacted
we've unfortunately had records of the
last uh a few uh days we've had a couple
of uh highs for florida uh i'm actually
in a covid hospital right now visiting a
40 year old who's in icu
so it's impacting people that are my age
it's it's impacting our children because
more children are hospitalized than
before significantly more um and so you
know this is a difficult time where
we're now uh have to make sure that
we're doing everything that we can
and getting vaccinated uh you know 99 of
the people that are vaccinated are not
experiencing serious complications and
90 of the people that are hospitalized
are not vaccinated so this is clearly a
pandemic of the unvaccinated hey mr
mayor are you seeing uh the debate over
whether to get vaccinated those that are
hesitant
in the mask mandates possibly coming
back are you seeing that really affect
your ability as a local leader to try
and get things under control
well what we've done in the city is for
our employees is you have to wear a mask
unless you're vaccinated so
obviously the preference would be for
people to be vaccinated because we're
seeing the statistics that show
overwhelmingly that if you're vaccinated
you don't suffer serious complications
and most of the people that are
hospitalized are not vaccinated so i
think we're starting to see a pendulum
swing where many people who are
resistant or who are hesitant to be
vaccinated are now seeing uh people that
are for example my age that are being
hospitalized or children that are being
hospitalized and i think that's changing
their minds
and i'm glad it is
so that's an interesting point mr mayor
you believe then that really this latest
sort of rising cases may convince those
that perhaps have been uh reticent to
embrace the protocols to maybe change
their mind
absolutely i mean like i said i'm here
visiting a friend of mine who's 43 years
old unfortunately he's in icu he was
unvaccinated because he was trying to
have a child and as a result of him
being in icu now every single one of the
people my group of friends who were not
vaccinated have become vaccinated so i
think that's going to happen over and
over and uh hopefully he'll be fine and
and hopefully more people will be
vaccinated
gosh i can keep talking to you mr mayor
about your state and the covet spike
there but let me because we have you in
this breaking news in haiti of this
earthquake uh i haven't spent a lot of
time in in little haiti there what are
you hearing from your haitian community
in miami as we get news of this
earthquake
well unfortunately it's another
devastating event that has happened in
haiti obviously they're reeling after
the assassination of their president uh
the the the you know the country is
disorganized from a political
perspective and for them to have
suffered an earthquake which could be
even greater than the one in 2010 with
massive aftershocks um you know it's
it's unclear exactly what the
devastation is or will be but the early
reports are not good and obviously
people are are extremely anxious here
and as far as your haitian community
goes there uh are you going to have any
sort of response to help them perhaps to
try and reach i know communication in
situations like this becomes really very
difficult
absolutely i mean we we have uh like you
said a little little haiti cultural
center um which which was created in the
city of miami
and it's probably one of the largest
diaspora diaspora of haitian uh haitian
americans are here in the united states
so we will be uh using that facility to
connect with the haitian community and
make sure that we're doing everything we
can in the city to support them here and
them over there and lastly in the 30
seconds we've got mr mayor we're glad
that a a hurricane named fred is not
hitting you but you are going to get
quite a lot of rain are you prepared
what are you concerned about
we sure are you know we're usually
prepared for hurricanes and for for
large hurricanes so this in a sense for
us being the big first storm of the of
the season is welcome news uh that we're
not gonna get the brunt of a storm and
we're prepared for it
mayor francis suarez of miami thank you
for taking time our thoughts and prayers
with your friend and all of those that
are in that hospital you're in right now
thank you mr mayor
thank you